ecstasy's have different different vibes
is that
is there an intentionally bad ecstasy
[Laughter]
this one makes you feel [ __ ] bad dude
when would you ever want to do that one
maybe you just have such a good life
what i want to feel paranoid take this
man
it's booger flavor this is the booger
flavor
what what is the jelly bean [ __ ] bert's
spurts every flavored
beans or whatever birdie bots every
flavored beans birdie bots yeah but it's
all
it's all different kinds of ecstasies
this makes you really itchy it gives you
a shape like an anchovy
yeah this one sucks dude this one sucks
why i mean you feel decent but it tastes
like fish and you just taste fish for an
hour
it's just mdma and xlax
[Laughter]
this one makes you roll and [ __ ] your
brains at the same time
this one it just gives you temporary
eczema for six hours it just makes you
really itchy and kind of euphoric it's
very strange
it's funny because like literally weed
is like that to me i just know it's
gonna make me feel like [ __ ]
and when i used to smoke it it's like i
went into it knowing that
i would feel bad yeah i know that once i
put this in my body i'm going to wish i
never did it
yeah yeah i've never had that reaction
to weed i was always surprised when you
told me that what about
like coffee though what about that
because you said coffee gave you anxiety
and for me it still does that but for
some reason i like the taste so much i'm
like i'm just gonna do it and even
though i know i'm gonna feel like ass
it's kind of like sorry go ahead no no
no no
you finished well i'm just gonna say it
it's like i remember hearing about my
friend's brother
that basically this guy he's like
really successful guy really you know
like he's kind of
hardened mentally right yeah really uh
determined and i don't know he's just
successful right yeah he felt like [ __ ]
for a certain period of time so he like
did this survey on himself where he
would just stop
eating and drinking a certain thing week
by week stop
drinking dairy stop drinking sugar or
eating eating sugar
for a week until he found what was
making him feel like [ __ ] i was like
that takes so much
uh self-control that i just don't have
man uh tom's home he went through
something similar he
was getting some crazy like he couldn't
figure it out
some crazy allergic reaction and he had
to go
on a similar diet it wasn't so extreme
it was the inverse he cut everything out
at once and then slowly added stuff back
in
but there was a month or five week
period where
you know for one week he's just eating
oatmeal and then the next week he has
something else something else and tom
showed me pictures this dude
dropped 20 pounds
he looked bad tom and
his friends would ask him are you alive
they all went and hung out at some lake
house and he fell asleep and
tom said they were joking i think
putting their fingers under his nose or
something to check if he's breathing
you know okay jesus christ
but yeah yeah do you think you could
ever like lose a [ __ ] on a weight for
a roll
like i look at stuff
i don't care about that art of acting
that much where i would say yeah i want
to
torture myself yeah yeah
i could i could get bought for a roll
that i can do i mean what if they said
like
five million bucks would you lose 15
pounds
like starve yourself
15 million is 15 million
what's my role like what's the movie you
are
um let's see
you are a skinny streamer
yup skinny screamer no no no no go ahead
go ahead go ahead go
what what's my movie what's my role you
work in a warehouse
okay and you are
sick no that's not
it's a really sad movie about you losing
a lot of weight
because you're sick
so just a guy at home depot with like
dysentery
yeah just diarrhea yeah
it's a really sad movie about you
pooping all the time i'm losing a bunch
of weight
come on daniel hurry up bring those
hoses here it's about to be
it's about to be gardening season we
need all the hoses at the front
ball so i can't i got the rear
again you always got the real boy move
those hoses
you sound like chappelle a little bit
oops did you watch his
by the way his monologue on i did i did
great right
he i mean you know other people have
said this i'm not the first one to say
this but you know he's just
um
i he's just in a such a mind state where
and i've seen people say that carlin got
to this point
where you know it was beyond stand-up
it's just public speaking yeah and i
think that's the craziest thing about
him is
he doesn't really have to joke so that
you want to watch him talk i think that
part is crazy
yeah now that's just such a
dope place to be in you just get on
stage and say i want to just pontificate
yeah yeah now i almost feel like some of
the jokes like took away from it at some
point
because we all just wanted to hear him
make an important statement
yeah on a day as iconic as that day
the thing i didn't catch that other
people noticed
was at the end of the monologue he said
good night and he dropped the microphone
but what i didn't catch was he's sort of
just implying
no one's going to watch snl and i didn't
even that part didn't even occur to me
because
i literally turned it off after he said
good night and i even processed the fact
that that was on snl there was a whole
show
afterward that i didn't give a [ __ ]
about i said oh so he didn't say welcome
to snl
at the very end he said good night and
he just threw the microphone down
jesus christ hard as nails bro that's
pretty dope he's like this is about me
yeah yeah
see ya sorry i had a joke and i lost it
but yeah
that [ __ ] was i so from that i just
a few days later i went back and watched
old chappelle show
just sketches and oh man
there's no way now oh yeah no
way any of that yeah oh man yeah
but they were hilarious jesus christ
dude
the opening one of season one where he's
parodying that old mitsubishi commercial
with the girl dancing
that [ __ ] just threw me for such a loop
because i was crying
first of all remembering that dumbass
commercial do you remember that [ __ ]
no it's the there's it was for the
eclipse and
it was just it was the eclipse with
these
you know extended exposure lights going
through the commercials she's just
in the in the eclipse like
oh oh yeah yeah i do remember that and
so the the bit was chappelle driving and
this girl's in the passenger seat and
they're listening to edm
and she just like won't stop dancing and
he's
looking at her saying does this [ __ ]
ever stop
[ __ ] is wrong with you
and then he kicks her out and he gets
another girl in the car and then
they're driving around the street and
they pass by
the girl that he kicked out and she's
just on the corner still
going at it that you can make that now
no you can definitely make that now but
there's this whole bit where
they show the uh they show
other footage that was cut out of the
other girl dancing in the car and like
her her titty pops out and they freeze
frame on chappelle
looking over at her tit
he's i'm just sitting there like come on
titty
i was like geez man hilarious
so funny then don't and
before all of you go oh noel thinks
titty's popping out it's funny i
yes i do titties are funny
titties can be very funny yeah you know
just
and awesome too tits are yeah yeah boobs
boobs are cool man hot take amp zonkers
god day cody likes breast
[Laughter]
and with that being said newt gingrich
everybody
newt how do you feel about titties
fighting out
you